j - 10 avant le premier tour des
élections législatives rendez vous aux
urnes le 12 juin pour élire vos députés
tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir plus clair
dans ce scrutin avec les enjeux dans
chacune des 12 circonscription des
yvelines avec moi ce soir aussi bixente
manière senti stevan de la rédaction tv
78 bonsoir bixente et avec vous on va
parler précisément d'une circonscription
et pas des moindres elle regroupe
cinquante et une commune presque un
tiers du département c'est la 10e
circonscription fait vous avez te dit
gregory en fait quand on prend la carte
des yvelines il ya deux circonscriptions
facilement identifiables par leur vente
superficie la 9ème à l'ouest et surtout
le sud du département donc la 10e elle
débute de maurepas et montfort l'amaury
au nord et décent jusqu'en bas de la
carte comprenant rambouillet
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines l'histoire
politique de cette circonscription est
très ancrée à droite avec quelques
exceptions surtout depuis les dernières
années de 1993 à 2007 c'est christine
boutin qui occupe le poste de député sur
la circonscription en tant que
représentante de l'udf puis de l'ump
réélu en 2007 mais choisi comme ministre
du logement et de la ville elle laisse
son siège à son suppléant jean frédéric
poisson et c'est là que ça se complique
après le remaniement ministériel de 2009
elle cède sa place de député ce qui
entraîne une élection législative
partielle remportée donc par
jean-frédéric poisson mais invalidée par
le conseil constitutionnel
une nouvelle des élections et donc
organiser des suites de celle là en
juillet 2010 et c'est une surprise le
parti europe ecologie les verts brigue
la mandature avec avec anny poursinoff
reste deux ans et en 2012 le retour de
la droite à la tête de cette 10e
circonscription avec jean frédéric
poisson encore désormais sous le parti
chrétien démocrate parti justement
fondée par christine boutin et enfin
lors des dernières élections la vague a
l'air est mort a eu raison de ce
territoire historiquement à droite aura
berger est élu au deuxième tour avec 64
% de suffrages exprimés et hazard des
chiffres pour cette nouvelle campagne
des élections législatives dans cette
10e circonscription oui une dizaine
circonscription avec dix candidats
officiellement inscrits en vue des 12 et
19 juin prochains on est sur une zone
convoitée par donc le parti de la
majorité présidentielle avec l'actuel
député rohr berger qui se représentent
mais le territoire est également briguée
par d'autres partis les républicains
tout d'abord ancrés localement est
représentée par anne k brimer redore son
ville et directrice du parc naturel
régional de la vallée de chevreuse
autres forces en présence nuxe l'union
de la gauche avec cédric dréau l'est de
la france sont soumises habituellement
dans les hauts-de-seine qui a déjà été
candidat au départemental à nanterre et
à la région ile de france et thomas du
chalard un temps directeur de la
communication de la mairie est reine de
mantes la ville pour le rassemblement
national pour rappel au premier tour des
présidentielles sur ce territoire jean
luc mélenchon avait récolté 19 % des
voix marie le pen 16% bien en dessous
des manuels macro à 32% purifiant si on
regarde dans le détail parmi les
candidats alignés en 2017 peut se
représenter en 2022 trois seulement sur
les quinze inscrits il ya cinq ans en
plus d'horreurs berger donc deux sont à
nouveau là en 2022 philippe chevrier
anciens rn désormais sous l'étiquette du
parti d'eric zemmour e conquête et
marielle saunier pour le parti de la
lutte ouvrière tous deux avaient récolté
moins de 1% des suffrages en 2017 enfin
pour terminer ce tour d'horizon quatre
autres candidats si wibaut gars pour le
parti animalistes claire couégnas de
debout la france michel bizien du parti
ouvrier indépendant et patrice jacono
sans étiquette merci bixente on rappelle
les dates de ce scrutin des élections
législatives premier tour le 12 juin et
2e tour le 19 juin prochain